MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
In this section, we'll
talk about waves.
You have all seen waves.
You know what a wave
is in principle.
You might have had an
opportunity to surf on a wave
just like the one behind me.
What we want to do here is
be more quantitative and more
precise in the
definitions, and also
look at different
sorts of waves.
I find this Wikipedia article
here quite interesting.
It starts with saying
that, in physics, a wave is
an oscillation accompanied
by the transfer of energy
that travels through
space or mass.
It continues then talking about
the various types of waves,
and it makes a distinction
between mechanical waves, which
travels through a
medium or substance,
and the deformation
of the substance
is reversed by restoring force.
In contrast, there's
electromagnetic waves,
which we have just seen
in the previous section.
They do not require
a medium, and that
is topic of the next section
as we continue the discussion
of special relativity.
Here, the electromagnetic
waves consist
of an oscillation of
electrical and magnetic fields,
which are generated
through charged particles.
Things that don't
require a medium,
they can travel
through a vacuum,
but an electromagnetic
wave can also
travel through a
medium like water
or anything else
you come up with.
It doesn't stop there really,
because the concept of waves
are really everywhere
in physics.
Specifically, when
you start studying
quantum mechanics and the
behavior of particles,
those are described by waves.
Really exciting
recent results are
those of the discovery of
gravitational waves, which
are vibrations or movement
of a gravitational field.
Also those don't
require a medium.
They travel through vacuum.
When we look at waves, we can
start characterizing them,
and one primary sort
of characterization
is the polarization of a
wave, meaning whether or not
the oscillation itself
happens in a transverse way
with respect to the
direction of movement,
or longitudinal to the
direction of movement.
Mechanical waves can be
transverse and longitudinal,
polarized, or have transverse
and longitudinal components.
Electromagnetic waves in free
space are transverse only.
So here's a picture of
a wave, sine or cosine,
and we can start with
the characterization.
One aspect is the amplitude.
How big is, for
example, the water wave?
How big is the
maximum strength of
the electric or magnetic field?
That's the amplitude.
Waves propagate and
they have a velocity.
That is a characterization.
The length of the
wave, the wavelength,
is another way to
characterize them.
In physics, it's always
important to understand
the units of the
object we discuss.
Here, just as a
reminder, the velocity
given in meter per second.
The frequency of your waves.
So how often do we find a
trough, for a wave for example,
per second.
The frequency 1 over second.
The wavelength is in meters.
We can continue with
the characterization
and be a little
bit more complete.
We can start from the
medium, the period,
the polarization, transverse and
longitudinal, the wavelength,
frequency, velocity,
or even how much energy
is being carried by the wave.
When we compare waves and
look at their properties,
we have to consider
the phase of the waves.
So where do, for example,
two waves line up,
the difference in phase
between two waves,
and some waves can interfere.
So if you have two
waves which interfere
and they are out of phase, like
the one drawn in this picture,
the resulting wave
has amplitude 0.
This is called
destructive interference.
You can have constructive
interference.
For example, when those
two waves are aligned,
there's no phase difference,
and then the amplitudes
you simply add.
The situation can
be more complicated.
When we study the
speed of a wave,
there are a number
of considerations.
The first one is that
the speed of a wave
depends on the medium
in which it travels.
And the study of the
speed or the velocity
dependent on the
medium is part of what
we will discuss in
the discussion of
whether or not there is a
medium responsible for carrying
electromagnetic waves.
The source.
So for electromagnetic waves,
you have a charged particle.
Does the speed of the source
change the speed of the wave?
The answer is no.
It changes the wavelength
or the frequency,
but the velocity is not changed,
and you find this, for example,
in sound waves in
the Doppler effect.
When you listen to
a police car, you
hear that the frequency changes
depending on whether or not
the police car is coming towards
you or driving away from you.
That is called the
Doppler effect.
That does not change the
velocity of sounds in air.
That's independent.
When your medium is moving,
that changes the velocity,
and so here you have to add
the velocities of the medium.
So for light, as
a summary, light
is an electromagnetic
wave which is
moving in vacuum with
speed C, and that
is independent of the source.
But you can ask, in which frame.
In which frame is that the
velocity of light, and what
is the medium, and that
is really the discussion
we want to carry on from here.
At the time, when Einstein
developed special relativity,
there was still a discussion
going on whether or not
electromagnetic waves are
of the nature of a particle
or of the nature of a wave
and whether or not that
wave moves in a medium,
which was called ether.
So we can then experimentally
determine this.
We can look at various
properties of our waves
and ask whether or not this is
consistent with the hypothesis
that this is a particle,
this is a wave in ether,
maybe both, maybe neither.
And we can then fill
a table like this one
here and answer the question.
So this is, again,
an opportunity
for you to stop the video
and think through this
and try to answer the
individual questions.
I do this here for you.
One characteristic of
light, at least when
there is no heavy
masses involved,
is that it travels
in a straight line.
That is certainly consistent
with light being a particle,
but it's also consistent
with it being a wave.
So the answer is
both are correct.
Interference and
diffraction pattern.
That's rather difficult to
describe for a particle model,
but waves, as we just
saw, can interfere,
and there can be diffraction.
Polarization.
What does it mean for a
particle to be polarized,
but waves can be polarized.
We have just seen transverse
and longitudinal polarization.
Light velocity depend
on the velocity
of the source velocity.
For particles, it
doesn't seem to hold.
For waves, this does.
And then, the last,
is the speed of light
greater in air than in water.
That's true for a wave.
For particles, you
might argue this one,
but I put a no in
this table here,
which means that in our
discussion up to this point,
clearly the hypothesis of a
wave for light and ether holds.
You'll see in the next sections
that there is aspects of light
where the discussion will not
hold like this, especially
for the ether hypothesis.